This video is brought to you by glasses,
USA more about them in a bit,
but if you want glasses up to 70% off retail,
follow the glasses USA link in the description,
you'll love it,
or they'll give you your money back and
let's get into it.
Mohandas Gandhi started out as a scared,
painfully shy young man,
yet he was transformed by injustice,
to step beyond his insecurities to become the 20th century's most influential
champion of social justice and the standard bearer for nonviolent resistance.
Here's example of humility.
Courage and quiet.
Dignity has inspired millions and it's been the catalyst for that change to a
better world.
In this week's biographics,
we discovered the inspirational story of the great soul,
Mahatma Gandhi.
Okay.
Mahindras Comma.
John Gandy was born on October the second 1869 in the coastal Indian town of
Poor Bandar.
He was the youngest of six children,
which included two half sisters from his father's previous marriage.
Monjas.
His father,
[inaudible] was the Dijuan or political leader of Paul Bandha.
His mother put Levi,
was deeply religious,
impressing strong Hindu beliefs on her children.
Could.
I'm trans,
provided well for his family.
He lived in a three story house and it's seven the Honduras was known by all
lists Mohammed.
He was especially devoted to his mother who he considered to be a saint.
Her piety made a deep impression upon him.
When the boy was five his father was appointed the chief minister of the smaller
inland city of ranch caught after two years.
The family that you joined him,
that one was a painfully shy Charles.
He kept to himself at school when it's Besson's with Don,
he would run home in order to avoid having to talk to any of his peers.
He was also a fearful child who was terrified of many things,
but especially the dark.
He found his solace in books which were if something,
if a constant companion when he was just seven years of age and this was the
Hindu costume.
Mohan became engaged to Casta muck Hangi [inaudible] who was a few months older
than him.
The arranged marriage was completed when Mohan turned 13 the planning for the
lavish wedding ceremony and adjustment to married life meant that he had to take
a year off from his schooling.
He was an average student at best,
though he tried hard to please as teachers,
you have no interest in sports games or social activities with any of his peers.
He did,
however,
make one friends around this time.
He wasn't Muslim boy by the name of shake Mahtab Jake was old Zuarin's more
street smart than Mohammed.
It was also physically larger and stronger than him.
He tried in Mohan about his frail condition and it's holding this.
If he ate meat,
he would get to much bigger and stronger.
No,
this was strictly against the Hindu belief,
especially.
Mohan met his friend in secret one day and he had his first taste of meat even
though they caused him to vomit he to eat it for the next year without letting
anyone else know.
During that period shakes hook into a brothel and experience,
which was an embarrassing disaster for the impressionable team.
Realizing that shake was a bit of a bad influence.
He caught off association with him and returns to a strict vegetarian diet.
Bowen's father calm John's died when the boy was 16 years old.
The grief was compounded when Bon and Costa was first child died less than a
week old.
The couple would go on to have four more children with the first being born in
1880 8 million completed college at the age of 18 and enrolled in some Aldous
college.
However,
he disliked the lecture style of teaching and dropped out after only a few
months.
He had set his sights on becoming a lawyer and eventually becoming a Duwan like
his father.
A family friends suggested that he should go to England to study where it was
easier to pass the bar.
It was agreed that this would be the best course of on the Shy Hindu boy was now
headed for the bright lights of London
on August the 10th 1880 8 million left his family including his wife and his one
month old son [inaudible] and he headed for Bombay where he bought it.
A ship that was bound for London.
Before leaving though he was something to be the leader of his cost to warns him
that if he went to England,
he would be tempted to break the rules of Hinduism.
He was told to either abandoned his plans,
will be excommunicated from the cost.
Gandhi accepted this consequence and he continued upon his way.
Fitting into Western culture though was that it was a shock to the 18 year olds,
everything.
It was so different,
so what he had known back in India,
it's still,
he did his best to fit in buying a fine suit,
complete with a leather gloves,
top hat and Silvertips cane.
He also paid for lessons and elocution manners and dumps.
His biggest challenge was with regard to his diet.
He had vowed to his mother that he was not going to eat meat,
but he was finding it very difficult to find restaurants that cater to
vegetarians.
His chronic shyness prevented him from requesting alternatives,
do what was on offer.
That finally though you found a vegetarian restaurants along with a whole
community of vegetarians and it was at this point so that he joins the nuns and
vegetarian society.
Just wait as difficulties with fitting into London in life.
Gandhi did well academically.
He passed his law exams in June of 1891 his friends at the vegetarian society,
they held a celebrator evening and is on it.
When it came time to give a speech.
However,
Mohan was so nervous that he simply rose and Tony said,
thank you.
Okay
on is returned to India.
Mohan was met at Bombay harbor by his older brother who bought some terrible
news,
his mother,
but Levi had died in his absence moons.
Grief was compounded with the consequences of his overseas foray.
He was now disfellowshipped from his cost in order to please his family members.
He agreed to bathe in a sacred river in order to wash away the sins of
England's.
This precipitated his reentry into the cost going.
Z books for work is a lawyer in Bombay.
However,
his chronic shyness was still preventing him from making any advancements.
He recalls how he fell is presenting his first case before the court saying my
head was reeling and it felt as if the whole court was doing likewise.
He retreats it to the nes imposing town of Raj Carlton,
just stablish to a small law office that shortly thereafter he received an offer
from the much and two had been a friend of his father.
This man was now based in South Africa and he needed a lawyer to help with the
court case.
The year long job was often to Gandhi and he accepted it.
Just finished recently becoming a father again.
He kept his wife and two young sons under the camera of his brother and he
headed off a Durban South Africa in April of 1893 officer settling into his new
surroundings,
guns.
He took the trains,
Pretoria where the court case was to be tried.
He purchased a first cost ticket.
However,
on one of the stops the European men bolted,
the car that he was in,
the men resented seeing an Indian and first costs and left to find the train
conductor.
The two men returned and has gone.
D was wanting to go down to the third class section.
God's.
He showed them his fitness costs tickets and refuse to move or to that's
trained.
Security was cooled and gum dia was kicked off the train.
He had to go to the rest of the way in a horse drawn carriage.
However,
the white passengers of that carriage,
they refuse to lessen Indians it inside with them and he was made to sit on the
outside foot board.
He lays it recalls.
The insult was more than I could bat.
This was the watershed experience of my hundred Gandhi's life as if by miracle
he shook off his timid nature and stepped forward as a leader of the oppressed.
When he arrived in Pretoria,
he called a meeting of the Indian community and gave the funniest speech of his
life cooling for the Indians to stand up for their rights.
Once his work on the court case was completed,
Gandhi decided to stay and continue to fight the Indian rights.
In 1894 he established the natal Indian Congress to give Indians a political
voice.
He established himself as a leader in the local community giving free legal
advice and offering support.
In 1896 off to three years in South Africa.
Gandhi,
writtens India to connect his family.
It returned with his wife and two sons who are now aged nine and five along with
a nephew.
Gandhi demanded that his family,
they dress as Europeans and eat with knives and forks as it was the way with
Indians in South Africa.
This goal tension within his family.
Still two more songs were added to the family and the coming years.
When the bow Walbro accounts in 1899 Gandhi fell to this.
If the Indian supported the government,
they would be rewarded with that or treatments.
He organized an Indian ambulance corps who are a valuable asset to the army,
but the loyalty,
it wins unrewarded with the harsh treatment continuing during this time gone.
D develops the life philosophy,
which was to going in for the remainder of his days.
They called it [inaudible],
which means devotion to the truth.
The three core tenants of the belief where noncooperation,
nonviolence and non possession.
In 1906 the South African province of Transvaal enacted a law that required all
Indians to register and be given identity cards.
The police were allowed to stop and demand their registration as any time.
No other group have this requirement.
Guns he advocated the use of saw Takahata counsel the law.
He told people not to register.
As a result,
he ends.
Many others were thrown in jail,
but Gandhi taught that righteous imprisonments was an honorable thing.
The concept of Satyagraha took hold and Gandia established a number of
cytochromes settlements.
The people in the settlements,
they practiced non possession,
living a simple and austere life guns.
He also organized a large coal miners' strike the men practice noncooperation by
refusing to work and nonviolence by refusing to react when they were attacked
spinal authorities.
In July of 1914 the South African government passed the Indian really fact which
wins some way to righting the wrongs that had been heaped upon the Indian
community.
The 20 years of struggle that Gandhi had put into the cause.
We're largely responsible for these changes and after this he was ready to
return to India,
bringing his philosophy with him.
And do you know what else he brought back to India with him?
His famous glosses?
Yes,
I absolutely just did that.
Welcome to an unexpected Abrie brought to you by glasses USA and you can,
there's a gandy wish they existed back when he wold glosses because fat just
excellent.
These ones that could,
would les,
and I've also got two others that you see me wearing from time to time.
There's one this,
there's also a bigger pair,
which I don't have all my little table here,
but you can also get them in a whole bunch of other styles.
They've got a huge range.
Some 4,000 options are available.
Then,
Hey,
they've also got designer sunglasses.
You saw me wearing these at the beginning of the video.
Now this isn't actually on the talking points,
but I believe what is perhaps the biggest testament,
the glasses USA,
is that this is my second pair of sunglasses from them.
A few months ago,
I lost a power while I was on holiday and by lost,
I mean I literally flushed them down the toilet by accident.
I really couldn't be making this stuff up and I had such a good experience with
glasses USA that I just went on the Internet and bought the same identical path.
They already had my prescription.
I just plugged it in and I bought a new pair.
That's exactly the same.
I think that really says a lot about how great it is.
You can also try them on online with a virtual mirror and the best thing of all,
it's super affordable glasses USA.
They cut out the middleman giving you prescription glasses and up to 70% off
retail and frames and lenses.
They start at just $30 plus a seat by quality lenses that every good as bit as
my old glasses that I had ages ago.
They were overpriced and just not as good and if you're not happy,
you can just send them back.
There's a hundred percent money back guarantee.
You can check out glasses,
usa.com in the link below and get a special deal on your first pair.
Let's get back to Gandhi and his non glasses.
USA specs.
Ooh,
gums or you were surprised to receive a hero's welcome back to India.
His efforts on behalf of South African Indians had been well reported over the
years and Indian poet referred to him as Mahatma meaning great souls and the
names are cold as a sign of the shy young man who had left in 1893 written
didn't 1915 as a leader and he was a leader with a mission and that of course
was Indian self rule.
Gandhi also challenged his own people to look at the unfair treatments within
their own culture.
He challenged the cost system and especially the terrible treatments of the
lowest class known as the untouchables.
He established a said Gog Raha settlements in which the people spun yarn and
farmed free trees gone.
The accepted on touchables into this community and taught the local peasants
proper hygiene and encouraged factory workers to wage peaceful strikes against
the unfair working conditions.
Despite his belief in nonviolence gone.
D did support the British war effort during World War One.
The wars ends,
the government Pasternack's making it illegal for any group to organize and
oppositions and the government's gone.
Z equals for a mass strikes at protest the Lawrence for one day,
the whole of India came to a standstill.
It was clear evidence of the power there's gone.
Dee was able to wield yes when reports filtered in that some Indians had
resorted to violence on the day of peaceful protest.
He was bitterly disappointed.
He knew at that point that as people as a whole,
we're not ready for sat gog Gra now the British were concerned that there would
be further outbreaks of violence.
And so a law was passed banning any gatherings of Indians in the city of
Amritsar.
One of the places where von instead of cut the following day was the beginning
of the religious new year.
And about 10,000 people gathered in the town square.
They have not yet how the news of the band as they were a piece for the
listening to a speech 90 soldiers and to Almond,
cause 10.
Dot.
They blocked off the only exit and proceeded to father weapons into the unarmed
crowd of men,
women and children.
379 people were killed that day with more than a thousand words being wounded.
In 1920 you're Ganti became the leader of the Indian national congress.
Advocating is nonviolent resistance and instituting strikes and boycotts to
bring pressure on the system gone and he told the people to boycott of British
cloth and spin their own IV out to spend time spinning every day and took to
wearing clothing made of hand spun cloth.
He made the spinning wheel and national symbol of Indian independence.
Goldade traveled throughout the massive countryside going mostly on foot.
He lives with the downtrodden in their makeshift to dwellings and listened to
their problems.
To them.
He was a saintly figure as they refer to him as babble,
meaning father.
In March 90 22 guards,
he was arrested for sedition.
The trial gave him the platform to expound upon the unfair treatment of Indians
and his refusal to cooperate with unjust laws.
These in guilty,
he was sentenced to six years in prison.
Mints Gone d though he was not deterred using his time of confinement of read
and study off two years he was released.
His focus was now on creating harmony between induce and Muslims.
For centuries,
the two groups had been at loggerheads with one another with Vaughn and clashes
often breaking out.
Gandhi saw that independence would be impossible without unity and he was
determined to bring these two groups together.
Gandhi undertook a hunger fast as a tool to bring the Hindus and the Muslims
together for three weeks.
He only drank water as they're bad people grew weaker by the day.
The Hindus and Muslims finally agreed to put aside their differences in order to
stop suffering.
Okay.
On march the 12th 1930 guarantee began a month long track from his Ashram and
under batch to the seed.
Hundreds and then thousands of followers of all religions and costs is joins him
along the way.
News of the march.
If fill papers around the world,
the British had long imposed a law making it illegal for anyone to make salt
from seawater in India.
As a result,
they were able to make huge profits from their salt tax.
24 days after setting out on his march to the sea,
Gandy Arrive Dondhi on the Gulf coast of Cambay.
The following morning,
Gandhi walked out into the sea water to bathe on Ezra town.
He picks up a handful of salts in defiance of the salt act.
This act was a signal for his countryman and up and down India's coastline.
Thousands of others began collecting seawater in order to make and sell salt.
Many were arrested,
including Gandhi,
who was thrown in prison for a second time.
You had the British could not silence.
Mahatma officials now realize that this man held a powerful sway over the
masses.
He simply could not be ignored any longer.
The more the British government,
both in India and at home were being pressured by other governments to release
Gandhi from jail.
Finally the British Viceroy in India.
Daughter when met with Gandhi after lengthy discussion,
they came to a truce,
gone.
D would cool off the demonstrations.
The prisoners would will be released and Indians would be allowed to make their
own salts.
In 1931 Gandhi traveled to London to represent the Indian national congress as
an international round table conference.
He called for Indian independence from Britain.
You can pinned,
done that.
We run
rather than mixed with the other delegates in their five star hotels gone.
The stayed with an old friend and spent his days walking around the slums,
dressed in his traditional whom spawn Cottey and his sandals he will is by now
the famous international figure runs.
Newsreels of his visits were shown in movie theaters all around the world.
Surely after returning to India,
Gandhi was again arrested for inciting civil disobedience.
While he was in prison,
the British government passed a law that discriminated against the untouchables
and court proceedings.
Gonzi was infuriated,
doesn't announce that he would not eat until this law was revoked fairing,
that his death would create a martyrdom that would doom them in the eyes of the
welds.
The authorities caved in.
The law was rescinded when Britain declared war on Germany.
In 1939 Gandhi told the authorities that Indians would only join the war fs if
they were promised their independence.
Three years later,
he started a quit India movement as always,
the plans for the campaign to be nonviolent,
especially things soon got out of hands and riots broke out across the country.
The authorities blamed Gandhians one small,
he was thrown in jail.
His beloved wife,
Christa,
was also imprisoned at this time and age.
She soon became ill,
dying in custody.
On February the 22nd 1944 following his wife's death,
Gandhi grew weak with malaria.
The authorities agreed to release him then may of 1944 and he went to Bombay to
recover and recuperate the end of World War II.
Saw great person on its knees though Victoria,
since it's spent exorbitant amounts in the war efforts and now no longer have
the results,
is to maintain its role within India with little choice in the massive person
offered India its independence.
It was the grand victory that Gandhi had been fighting for for the past 30
years.
Even though the nation was now free to rule itself,
India was still plagues with deep division between Hindus and most of them's the
only solution seemed to be to divide the country up and do Hindu,
India and most of them Pakistan.
This was a move that was greatly displeasing to Gandhi who loaned the unity
between these two groups.
In the weeks following the creation of Pakistan,
there were violence clashes between Muslims and Hindus up and down the country.
Massek as a could throughout 1947 with both sides being equally responsible for
the bloodshed.
Hundreds of thousands of people died and there were riots in most of the major
cities.
On January the 13th of 1948 the 78 year old gone day began the fost in order to
get the madness to stop.
He was so despondent that he refused to even drink water.
Despite the physical pain that he was in.
He still lead a pram.
Meeting from his bet is wads were broadcast around the entire country.
Five days into his fost.
Muslim and Hindu leaders agreed to a piece of court.
However,
Gandhi was still very concerned about the direction the fledgling nation was
taking.
The new prime minister Jawaharlal Nehru was constantly at odds with his deputy
Vallabhbhai Patel and gone.
Z counseled both men to make peace.
On January the 30th 1948 he was in a meeting with Patel just after 5:00 PM he
came out into the gods and a bill,
a house in Delhi to offer prowess weakened from his recent Fasti,
leans on two of his followers for support as he walks a crowd of some 500 people
were waiting to greet him as he made his way to the platform or Hindu extremist
Angus Gandhi's leniency towards the Muslims snapped forward.
He bowed before the Mahatma and then pulled out a pistol and fired three shots
and succession of pointblank range within half an hour.
The last breath of life.
It seeped out of his body and the great soul with no more.
When he had the news of Mahatmas death,
the prime minister stated the light has gone out of our lives and there is
darkness everywhere.
Hundreds.
Gandhi was a light,
not just to the people of India,
but those of the entire wells.
His funeral procession through the streets of Delhi was attended by more than 2
million people and years after his death,
countless of the millions,
including a young Baptist minister from Georgia named Martin Luther King,
would find inspiration in his words and in his legacy.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did do give us a like below,
and don't forget to subscribe.
Also check out glasses USA.
It's just a great deal.
You'll find a link in the description below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.